this may not look very tasty to some
people
but there are those who say it's the
food of the future
take 25 year old hamco mensing for
example
he turned an old pig farm into a
vertical farm for mealworms
they are used for pet food but as soon
as their new housing is finished
they may soon find their way to kitchens
all over europe
nutritional values of the mealworms are
really good they are low in fat
and they have a lot of protein and
producing the mealworms
has a very small footprint both in
carbon emissions energies of it doesn't
take a lot of energy to produce them
well it's a small
nuttery flavor but if you put some salt
in it you get extra
flavor from it as a chef he has been
teaching people how to use
insects in their dishes
after frying some crickets he uses them
for a salad with fermented tomato
and paprika i'm going to make desserts
of small
tree bowler worms with some
apple and then some raspberries
and a white chocolate cream fine dining
on beetles crickets or worms for many in
this part of the world this may be
too exotic experts call this the yuck
factor and this chef
doesn't believe that insects for human
consumption will soon become very
popular
but i can assure you that this cricket
salad
is very tasty
the worms are more expensive than beef
because of the cost of the production
yeah it's not the
normal thing that the dutch eat
but yeah they have to get used to it
and they prefer cheese they prefer
cheese yeah and all different kind of
meats also vegetables of course
this is being used in in shakes and and
beverages it contains
up to eighty percent protein this is all
made from buffalo beetles
after the mealworm this insect is also
being considered as novel food by the
european food and safety agency
the company says there's a way to
convince people to eat insects and that
is not to show them as
insects it's not the way it should be
presented we do not ask
people to eat whole insects and
that is that is what's different and
that needs to change and that's also a
change that needs to happen in the
mindset
of of food producing companies
so even for those who are breeding them
these worm cookies may still be a little
too innovative although with a bit of
added chocolate the yuck factor seems to
disappear
completely step faster al jazeera ostel
beers in the south of the netherlands